[Music]
it's a couple's night out for longtime
friends kendall jenner and hailey bieber
seen here out and about with their loves
devon booker and justin bieber i'm
excited in these new snaps the famous
duos are holding hands after dining out
in santa monica kendall wears a sheer
top and leather pants while devon pairs
his jeans and sneakers with a pink shirt
and tan jacket haley sports a black
halter dress and boots to match with
justin donning a colorful sweater
underneath a black leather jacket and
some shades it's the first time the
couple have been spotted together since
her health scare last week haley was
briefly hospitalized for a blood clot
sharing her story to instagram haley
wrote i started having stroke-like
symptoms and was taken to the hospital
they found i had suffered a very small
blood clot to my brain which caused a
small lack of oxygen but my body had
passed it on its own and i recovered
completely within a few hours i know for
a fact
that god has her in the palm of his
hands
justin later praised his wife in the
middle of his concert most of you
probably know or seen
the news about my wife i'm not sure if
you guys seen
but she's okay
she's good
she's
strong but it's been scary you know like
it's been really scary
the pics also come after devon booker's
recent comments about his relationship
with kendall jenner according to devon
their low-key romance took a little
while to settle in i don't know i just
kind of i like to keep my private life
pretty private and now he tells the wall
street journal honestly i'm enjoying
life to the fullest and that came off my
tongue so easily because it wasn't
always this way but i feel like i'm in a
good place right now this comes with new
details et is learning about the couple
the source tells et they love that they
can genuinely be themselves around each
other it takes no effort and things are
easy the source adds they get along so
seamlessly and have fallen really hard
for one another it's serious for sure
[Music]